[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
youtube plays immediately shrink bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic not spacey
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity wave
coming your way you have to launch now
did he say gravity wave
we're underwater guys
uh that's crazy
what's the plan save the mill and save
earth
wait for it
let's go you son
[Music]
everybody hang on i'm gonna get you
[Music]
home it's on airplane mode
[Music]
[Music]
you